the year is 1850 and the american
whaling industry is booming whale
hunting is an extremely risky business
but it's also incredibly lucrative each
expedition costs a fortune and one third
of all ships don't make it home but
successful trips are returning 10 times
the upfront investment so rich people
start spreading bets across different
whalers to diversify risk the plan works
out and lots of investors get rich but
eventually america stops using whale oil
and switches to petroleum john d
rockefeller is the biggest winner during
the oil boom and becomes the richest
person in history by building the
standard oil company the rockefeller
fortune gets passed down to his family
and in 1946 his descendants are looking
for new ways to deploy all this capital
so they start funding risky new
businesses but at this point they're
really just treating these investments
like charity and aren't thinking like
venture capitalists yet the first real
attempt at making money through early
stage investing comes out of boston a
group called american research and
development begins making investments in
several military technology companies
it's a good proof of concept but
startups that took money from ard were
required to give up 70 ownership in
order to receive funding even worse the
ard investment fund is set up as a
corporation instead of a partnership
which leads to all sorts of legal
headaches including a raid by the
securities and exchange commission but
on the other side of the country a few
san francisco stockbrokers are forming a
group to invest in technology startups
they need a name so they call it the
group fortunately for them they're
better at investing than coming up with
brand names and the founder of the group
is able to turn fifteen thousand dollars
into one million by investing in a
company that makes tape recorders analog
technology wouldn't last long though
even in the sixties people could already
tell that the future was digital and
everything digital requires
semiconductor chips now at the time all
the best engineers are working for
william shockley shockley is running a
semiconductor company called shockley
semiconductor yet another creative brand
name but shockley is a terrible boss so
eight of his brightest employees decide
to become traitors and leave the company
fortunately there's a new venture
capitalist in town named arthur rock and
he says let's call these guys the
traitorous eight and then gives the
money to start fairchild semiconductor
this looks really promising they're
finally making silicon chips in silicon
valley now and the us government takes
notice see it's the cold war and the
united states needs cutting-edge
technology to win the space race so they
start subsidizing venture funds known as
small business investment companies this
doesn't work though since each fund has
to be smaller than four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and they can't
give more than sixty thousand dollars to
a single startup no one wants to work
under these government limitations so
the private sector has to step up to
fill the void arthur rock was really on
to something with the traitorous eight
though he made seven hundred thousand
dollars and proved the convincing
talented scientists to quit their jobs
and start something new could lead to
big innovation so he doubled down see
rock recognized something that no one
else did even though most new ventures
would fail one big grand slam would
completely cancel out all the mistakes
normal distributions are what most
people expect when thinking about likely
outcomes you know the familiar bell
curve but venture capital investing
follows a power law with an extremely
long tale of huge winners this tiny
shift in mindset would dramatically
change the way new businesses got funded
it's still only 1968 but rock's model is
already working he winds up returning
more than 22 times his initial
investment which was enough to beat out
warren buffett's performance at the time
rock realizes that the power law is well
extremely powerful no one is thinking
about early stage investing this way so
he repeats the formula and helps two
members of the traitorous eight start
intel rock couldn't stay on top forever
though two new venture capitalists just
joined the party and we're about to
change everything it's 1972 and two big
vc firms launch don valentine found
sequoia capital and eugene kleiner
starts kleiner perkins both had worked
at fairchild semiconductor and seen
firsthand how the venture capital model
could supercharge new technologies but
there's one big question at this point
how closely should vcs and startups work
together traditionally the vcs had
mostly just written checks and then
turned the engineers loose to go build
well sutter hill wants to test that
theory so in 1973 they create the queue
model which pairs a talented inventor
with a strong outside ceo to help them
build the business this model seems to
be working so don valentine funds atari
which has some amazing game technology
but is basically a complete mess on the
business side kleiner perkins also wants
to get more hands-on so they build
tandem computers in-house and then spin
it out into an independent startup but
there's clearly more to silicon valley
than just silicon computer chips and
kleiner perkins knows this so they fund
genentech to commercialize recombinant
dna technology it's a super risky
venture but by investing slowly one
stage at a time kleiner winds up
building a new model for highly capital
intensive businesses it's 1977 now and
we finally get our first real household
name it's apple computer and
surprisingly steve jobs gets rejected by
lots of venture capitalists when he
tries to raise money that doesn't matter
though because there's finally a network
of vcs in silicon valley and if one says
no you can just go to a different
investor three years later both apple
and genentech go public and yield
massive profits for their investors
everyone in silicon valley is pumped and
wants to double down on the venture
model now the east coast isn't asleep
during all of this new enterprise
associates starts to build a venture
presence on the east coast but silicon
valley is still stronger just look at
the story of bob metcalfe he invented
ethernet cables and basically made the
modern internet possible but he couldn't
get east coast vcs to invest at the
terms he wanted so he wound up building
his company in silicon valley
everything's going well in california
but now investors have to make a choice
up until this point venture capitalists
took a very general approach investing
in whatever technology seemed to be on
the cutting edge arthur patterson and
jim schwartz think that there's a better
way though so they start excel capital
to specialize in particular industries
instead of looking at a semiconductor
company one week and then a biotech
company the next excel chooses to drill
down and focus just on telecom companies
the 80s are a boom time for silicon
valley not only are tech companies doing
extremely well but tax laws and
financial regulations are changing to
supercharge the venture capital model
capital gains taxes just dropped and now
pension fund managers can allocate money
towards venture capital this leads the
total size of vc funds to quadruple to
12 billion dollars in just six years vcs
have more money now and are becoming a
lot more powerful and the question of
how much control investors should have
over the companies that they fund pops
up again it's 1987 and sequoia makes an
incredible investment in cisco but they
wind up overhauling the management team
in the process sequoia becomes the first
vc firm to ever make more than a hundred
million dollars on a single investment
and it's a huge win but this would wind
up changing the way founders think about
maintaining control in future silicon
valley cycles things really start to
heat up in the 90s john doerr funds a
company called go with the hopes of
basically building an ipad but it fails
that doesn't matter though because of
the power law vcs have fully embraced
the idea of swinging for the fences
after all venture investments have
unlimited upside and the 90s are the
perfect time to embrace this mindset
excel nea and menlo ventures team up to
fund uu net which takes the
government-run internet and brings it to
the public the internet is still very
primitive at this point though so
netscape pulls in funding from kleiner
perkins to build a new web browser
there's still a big problem with the
internet though it's hard to find stuff
so in 1995 sequoia invests in yahoo and
the search engine market starts growing
everyone in silicon valley can see how
important search is going to be and
international funds start taking an
interest masayoshi's son has a massive
war chest and wants a piece of the
action so he goes to yahoo and offers to
write them a 100 million dollar check
the yahoo team is hesitant no one's
really ever done a deal like this before
but they don't like the idea of a
competitor having 100 million dollars in
the bank so they take it growth
investing has finally arrived and it's
shaking things up amazon also gets going
in the 90s and again john doe gets
kleiner perkins in early and makes an
absolute killing on the deal at this
point he's clearly silicon valley's top
internet investor but plenty of vcs
would be coming for his crown soon the
next big 90s breakout is ebay the
auction site is growing exponentially
and benchmark's bob kegel makes an
incredible early investment most venture
capitalists are scrambling to raise
bigger and bigger funds but benchmark is
staying lean and focused and winds up
generating a 5 billion profit on the
ebay investment but things are changing
for traditional venture capital firms
with so many successful companies in
silicon valley individuals can now help
startups get off the ground directly now
google isn't the first company to raise
money from angel investors but when
sergey brin and larry page raise a full
1 million dollars without even talking
to vcs it's clear that the landscape is
shifting 1999 was in some ways the dawn
of the fully empowered tech founder
larry and sergey were engineers but they
dictated aggressive terms to both
kleiner perkins and sequoia when they
raised their series a these two rival
firms wanted the whole round to
themselves but the google founders knew
that they had leverage and they
exploited it one of the hardest things
about building a new business is
attracting talent small startups don't
have the cash to outbid bigger companies
on salary but stock options provide a
solution to this problem all of a sudden
a talented engineer could essentially be
granted a big ownership stake in the
business all with zero upfront tax
liability stock options were fuel on the
innovation fire in silicon valley but
the secret about their power was out and
it wasn't long before goldman sachs
brought them to china while financing
the e-commerce site alibaba it's now the
new millennium and internet companies
hit a turning point people are freaking
out about y2k computer bugs and the
attention on technology is reaching new
heights vc firms now have 104 billion
dollars under management but things are
about to get rocky during the dot-com
bust suddenly everyone realizes that
even though these technologies are
amazing there just aren't enough people
using them the numbers don't add up and
the dot-com bubble bursts the market
sell-off doesn't really matter though
because the smart investors realize that
this new technology will eventually win
out so the big players start adjusting
softbank winds up making a fortune on
alibaba which offset its u.s tech losses
and tiger global becomes the first hedge
fund to cross over into startup
investing a few years after the dot-com
bust tech is back on track google goes
public and interestingly they use a
dual-class share structure which ensures
that the founders will remain in control
forever it's becoming clear that great
founders are capable of thinking in
decades and planning for extreme
long-term growth so in 2005 peter thiel
launches founder's fund with the core
mission of supporting founders for the
long haul it's a different approach from
traditional venture capital but he's not
the only one developing new ways to
build startups paul graham and jessica
livingston launch y combinator which
essentially creates the startup
incubator model their plan is simple
back promising founders earlier than any
venture capitalist would and focus on
highly technical individuals facebook is
also starting to change how silicon
valley operates by the mid-2000s mark
zuckerberg is going around the valley
pitching investors in pajama pants and
still getting term sheets he does run
into a problem though after five years
of solid growth most tech companies
would go public but yuri milner offers
zuckerberg an alternative see milner had
done extensive research into facebook's
growth numbers and could tell that the
site was going to be massive instead of
a traditional ipo why not take a large
growth equity round and stay private
longer it was an uncommon path at the
time but it would quickly become
immensely popular with a huge wave of
tech companies reaching new heights
toward the end of the decade marc
andreessen and ben horowitz launch a new
venture partnership the name andreas and
horowitz is a bit long so everyone
shifts to calling them a16z
mark and ben realized that startups are
all about talent so they modeled their
firm on the prominent hollywood talent
agency caa remember how sequoia got
squeezed out of taking the full google
series a well in 2010 they invest in the
chinese shopping company meitwan and
wind up making more money on that bet
than they did on google even though
china's tech industry was delivering
incredible returns america wasn't
slowing down by 2013 there are so many
late-stage tech companies worth more
than a billion dollars that we need a
special word for them how about unicorn
those are rare right well they wouldn't
be for long in 2017 masa launches the
nearly 100 billion dollar vision fund
all of a sudden any startup with solid
growth numbers can stay private for
years and raise hundreds of millions of
dollars dozens of new unicorns are
created overnight it's shaking up the
industry and sequoia isn't happy about
it mike moritz is worried that all this
cheap capital will distort the market
for technology investments so sequoia
fights back with an 8 billion growth
fund vcs now have more money than ever
before and this unlocks some unique
opportunities elon musk had proven that
the right founder could disrupt pretty
much any industry as long as they had
enough runway to work on the problem for
decades founders fund had witnessed this
firsthand when they broke through in
defense contracting with palantir and
spacex so they doubled down and back
under founders can now raise billions of
dollars in venture capital all without
losing control over their companies when
it works out everyone gets rich together
but if there are bumps in the road
things get messy in 2018 benchmark goes
to war with travis kalanick for control
of uber it's a big turning point in the
extremely founder-friendly environment
and things don't stop here then wework
tries to ipo but ultimately has to pull
the offering there's a big messy fight
for control over the company and people
start thinking that maybe these big
startups are staying private too long
and that brings us to today two years of
lockdowns have fueled even more growth
in new technologies and now 900 billion
dollars is sitting in venture capital
all this money is hunting for the next
big breakout but it's unclear where the
industry will go from here if you want
to learn more you really have to read
this book called the power law by
sebastian alibi it's an incredible read
i'll link it below the power law
demonstrates the importance of finding a
few huge successes early on with so much
money chasing so few opportunities the
typical return targets might need to
adapt the entire goal of venture capital
is to outperform the s p 500
no one wants to pay management fees to a
venture capitalist if they could earn a
better return by buying an index fund
and that brings me to today's sponsor
masterworks dot io the contemporary art
market has historically been a bit like
venture capital you had to be incredibly
wealthy in order to build a portfolio of
art at least until masterwork's launched
see masterworks allows you to invest in
world-famous artworks from banksy monet
and other iconic artists for just a
fraction of what these pieces typically
cost and this is interesting because the
contemporary art market hasn't behaved
like most other financial assets in fact
contemporary art prices outpaced the s p
500 total return by 164
from 1995 to 2021. putting together a
portfolio of contemporary art would
normally cost millions of dollars at the
very least but masterworks offers a
secondary market where you can trade
shares with other members just like you
would sell a stock on a trading app
getting started with masterworks is
super easy you just visit their website
create an account browse their artwork
and then start diversifying your
portfolio with one of the most stable
assets around i find masterwork so
fascinating because it unlocks an
entirely new market and that's what most
of the stories on this channel are all
about you can skip the waitlist by
clicking the link in the description and
it helps support the channel so go check
it out and if you're looking for more
amazing silicon valley history go watch
this video about how elon musk built
spacex it's a really incredible story
thanks for watching